this Nigerian man has just one goal to
go to Europe and leave a life of poverty
behind Albert is an unemployed business
manager and determined to reach Europe
at any cost his passage is already
organized people traffickers will take
him across the Sahara Desert to Libya
and then by sea to Italy I've tried so
many times many times past my CV some
oil many places still no job
many Nigerians are trying to flee the
Islamist extremist militia Boko Haram
the group has been terrorizing the north
of the country for years others like
Albert come from the slums of Nigeria's
big cities they simply want to escape
poverty corruption and social injustice
this year alone more than 12,000
Nigerians tried to reach Italy by boat
it's not known how many didn't make it
the authorities in Nigeria seem
reluctant to discuss the issue all our
requests for interviews were denied
every month thousands of Nigerian seek
their home country and risked their
lives trying to reach Europe meanwhile
Nigeria's leaders remain silent
something they often accused of doing
when it comes to sensitive political
issues but even I Jarius media are
practically ignoring the topic
television journalist if young a cop is
one of the few Nigerian journalists who
regularly report about immigration he
tells us that many of his colleagues
regard the problem as a European one a
cop thinks it's more important to find
the root cause of why so many Africans
want to leave her homeland it isn't that
the African journalist or the media here
are not aware of the impacts that
migration has caused better really
African media we don't seem to give too
much importance or attention to the
migration issue which I think it's wrong
more reports about migration would do
nothing to deter Albert from making his
plan a reality tonight he's hunkered
down in an old guest house tomorrow the
journey continues watching football
makes the dream of living in Europe feel
closer than ever before